Let's do some SAT problems.
Let's see, we're starting test
5 now and it's problem
number 1.
This is page 652.
According to a certain recipe,
20-- I'm getting deja-vu, this
looks like a question I did in
the last test, but maybe this
is different-- 25 pounds
of flour are
needed to make 300 rolls.
So 25 pounds per 300
hundred rolls.
At this rate, how many
pounds of flour are
needed to make 12 rolls?
Well, we can make
a ratio here.
So I need 25 to do
300 rolls, right?
But they're asking us well, how
much do I need if I only
need to do 12 rolls?
So 12 is what fraction of 300?
Whatever that fraction is, the
fraction of rolls of pounds of
flour I need to use will
be the same fraction.
Let's say that this is
x is the pounds of
flour I need to use.
So x is to 25 as twelve
is to 300.
And I can tell you from
inspection that 12 over 300 is
the same thing as 1/25.
If you don't believe me,
divide 300 by 12 and I
come up with that.
Well, you know 25 goes into
100 4 times and then
4 times 3 is 12.
If you don't believe me,
you can confirm this.
And they did it on purpose
because this is the first
problem, which tends
to be a quick one.
So x over 25 is equal to one
over 25, so x equals 1.
So you need 1 pound of flour.
And you could have also set the
ratio up like this: you
could have said 25 is to
300 as x is to 12.
This would have also worked.
Here we would have put the rolls
all on one fraction and
we could've put the pounds
of flour all
on the other fraction.
Next problem.
Switching colors.
Problem number 2.
If xy is equal to 10, what is
the value of 2 times x divided
by y times y squared?
Well the trick here is you've
got to simplify this
expression before you attempt
to do anything.
And simplifying, what's x
divided by y times y squared?
Well this right here, this is
the same thing as xy squared
divided by y, right?
We could put the 2 out here.
And see, we have a 2 on top and
the y on the bottom is the
same thing as y to the first,
so this is the same thing.
What's y squared divided by y?
Well it's just y, right?
So we get 2x and y squared
divided by y is just y, right?
The squared cancels out
with this entire term.
This just gets 1.
I divide the top and
the bottom by 1.
So all I'm left with is 2xy, and
we know that xy is equal
to 10, so 2 times 10 is 20.
That's choice e.
Next problem.
Problem 3.
Let's see if I can fit it on
this without having to-- x
plus y is equal to 30.
I might be talking funny.
I just came from the dentist.
And x is greater than 8.
Which of the following
must be true?
Well, we know x is greater than
8, and we also know that
x is equal to 30
minus y, right?
I just subtracted y from both
sides of that equation.
x is equal to 30 minus y.
Well we also know that x is
greater than 8, so 30 minus y,
which is the same thing
as x, must also be
greater than 8, right?
30 minus y is also going
to be greater than 8.
And we could play with
this a little bit.
We could add y to both
sides and get 30 is
greater than 8 plus y.
We could subtract 8 from both
sides and then you get 22 is
greater than y, or y
is less than 22.
And that's choice b.
Next problem.
Problem 4.
I'm writing in toothpaste color
in honor of my recent
visit to the dentist. OK,
what do they have here?
They have three points.
So point p, which
is 3 comma 2.
Point q, which is 7 comma 2.
And point r, which
is 7 comma 4.
The coordinates of points p, q,
and r and the xy plane are
given above.
What is the perimeter of pqr?
Let's draw that real fast. I
think that'll make things make
more sense, especially
if you missed it
the first time around.
So p is 3 comma 2.
So 3 comma 2, approximately.
q is 7 comma 2, so this is 3.
So this is going to be
a straight line.
And what's this length
going to be?
Well, it's going to be 4 because
it's going from 3 to 7
and we have no change in the
y, they're both at 2.
Then we have r is 7 comma 4.
It's going to be roughly
over here.
This is q, this is r.
And what's this distance?
Well we had no change it x, so
the distance is just going to
be the change in y,
so this is just 2.
And now we have to-- and this is
r-- and now the only thing
we have to do to finish
this problem is
figure out that distance.
And how do we figure
out that distance?
Well this is a right triangle,
so we could use the
Pythagorean theorem.
2 squared-- this is the
hypotenuse, right?
The green side I drew, that's
the longest side and it's
opposite the 90-degree angle,
so it's the hypotenuse.
So 2 squared plus 4 squared is
equal to-- let's call this x--
is equal to x squared.
So this is 4 plus 16 is
equal to x squared.
20 is equal to x squared.
So x is equal to the
square root of 20.
So x is equal to-- let's try to
simplify this, that's the
square root of 4
times 5, right?
And we know what the square
root of 4 is, so we
can take that out.
So that's x is equal
to 2 root 5.
I find that this is actually
where most people have a lot
of trouble, simplifying
root 20 to 2 root 5.
All we did is we factor 20 as a
product of a perfect square
and another number that's
not a perfect square.
And then we took the
perfect square out.
We said the square root of 4 is
2, so we can take it out.
So x is 2 root 5.
So what's the perimeter?
It's 4 plus 2 plus 2 root 5.
So 4 plus 2 is 6
plus 2 root 5.
Now let me see what
the choices are.
Oh, I didn't even have
to do 2 root 5.
They actually have choice
c says 6 plus the
square root of 20.
So I didn't even have to do this
but that's good to know.
This, what I did here,
is good to learn.
But they made it so we didn't
have to do that.
So it never hurts to glance at
your choices before you move
forward like I just did.
Invert colors.
I'm getting tired of this
color, so I will switch.
Problem number 5.
They give us a sequence: 8,
17, 26, 35, 44, and so on.
The first five terms in a
sequence are shown above.
Each term after the first is
found by adding 9 to the term
immediately preceding it.
Which term in the sequence
is equal to 8 plus 26
minus 1 times 9?
Fascinating.
So each term is equal to 9 plus
the previous term, right?
So the first term, let's
say term one, let's
call this the term.
Term one is 8.
Term two, let's call
this t for term.
Term two is 17.
And an equation we could have
gotten that is we could've
gotten 8 plus 2 times-- oh
sorry, 8 plus 9 times what?
The term minus 1, right?
Because that's just 8 plus
9 so if the term is 2,
2 minus 1 is 1.
So we multiply it times
9 and we add it to 8.
Similarly, the third
term, which is 26.
That's essentially
8 plus 16, right?
So that's 8 plus-- I'm
sorry, 8 plus 18.
So it's 8 plus 9 times--
once again, t minus
1, or 3 minus 1.
Right here it's 2 minus 1,
here it's 3 minus 1.
So in general, this
is the t-th term.
This is the equation of the t-th
term, which looks oddly
familiar to what they give
us in the beginning.
And if we do a little pattern
matching, we see that t is
equal to 26.